so recently I was invited to have lunch
with a lady that's running for Congress
from one of their for one of the
districts in California and I was
obviously very honored to go to that
luncheon as we started talking she told
me her story for Sur background and why
she was inspired to run for Congress and
he wanted me to endorse her and support
her and so I started posing some
questions and this happened literally
the week after Time magazine comes out
with the article right on the cover of
it saying the United States of Texas and
when you read some of the stats I wanted
to really know this is not just directed
to her this is where any of our
politicians in the state of California
why this keeps happening to California
I'll give you some numbers that it kind
of covered and the article one was in
the last 20 years in the last 20 years
four million people from California have
moved to the state of Texas so for every
183 thousand people that moved to Texas
100,000 are mobile from Texas to
California right and you continue and
study the numbers and he said wises
taking place where let's look at some of
the numbers California's population is
38 million Texas is populations roughly
26 million you look at the pros and cons
and he said well what's the state taxes
in California if you make $50,000 per
year you're making rub you paint roughly
nine point three percent in taxes and it
goes all the way up to 13.3% in
California if you live in Texas your
state taxes are zero you literally pay
no taxes for real estate taxes
California you're paying roughly 1.25 in
California for Texas you're paying
roughly 1.8 in the state of Texas Texas
for real estate should benefits
California in that area but the property
value California average property value
that's listing prices 772 the average
listing price in Texas is to nine you're
about less than half maybe a third of it
right so you sit down and go back and
forth with these numbers and you say
what's better in California and in Texas
why I have to definitely say the Lakers
are 10 times better than the Mavericks
and I just found that right now my
camera guy's a maverick
ban him so he's going to get fired right
after this episode we should but he told
me so Mavericks from who would want to
be a Mavericks fan right but he's a
Mavericks fan he said California's got
the 49ers Dallas would say they got
their American team unit got the Cowboys
right we got the angel who got the
Dodgers they got the Rangers right they
got the Spurs we got two Golden State
Warriors we can go back and forth on
what's Pedram who's better but I think
when you think about it the article in
Time magazine stated that those that
want entitlement programs are moving to
California and those that want to be
left alone and create jobs are moving to
Texas they call it the Cowboys of
business or movin in Texas and when you
look at unemployment rate in the state
of California were ranked number
forty-seven eight point nine percent
unemployment rate you look at Texas
roughly six point for direct number
seventeenth in all of America all the
states for unemployment rate why is that
why is it that that's taking place so as
I wouldn't ask this question from the
Congress mushy or something and have an
answer and she said you know what I
honestly don't know what we would
because I want to know what would you do
to keep business in the state of
California not believe it and I think in
every single thing we look at it doesn't
matter what it sports whether it's
magazines books churches whenever you
look at TV movies there's always only
dog there's always a leader that's ahead
of everybody else in this category for
the states in America Texas just happens
to be the leader in creating jobs
creating an economy creating a place
where people want to move to so my
message of the week would be to all the
other states in America maybe we can
learn a thing or two about what Texas is
doing with their people and their state
to attract so many hard-working business
owners that want to go out there move to
Texas it's my message do we
you